Her low freak bitches.
I can just see him in his mind.
I mean,
he loves me and he doesn't,
it doesn't bother him until he did.
He did.
He doesn't get embarrassed,
but he has to,
but you can see them guarding his loins.
You know,
like God.
Did she just say that
freshman year's guard thing?
His lawyer,
his lawyer guard thing.
I don't even know what that means.
Gert thing.
What does Curtin good clip it.
I think you're the first
person on this podcast.
Ever say to me,
oh,
that's hilarious.
Gert Ding spelling.
Gerd,
Gerd.
Jimmy.
You never heard that before,
have you?
This is the first time in all my years
I've heard girding girding your loins.
I would imagine be clenching.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
I just context put it together.
Occurred.
Here you go and circle
a with a belt or a band.
A young woman.
A young man was a,
wants to be girded with
a belt of knighthood.
Oh,
okay.
Cure up Scottish guard.
What makes sense?
Girding you're talking about constricting.
Girdy gird your loins lions.
Gotcha.
Get ready or gear up
your loins.
Wow,
that's a good one.
You're learning on this show.
This is a,
this is a show of it.
Mind,
there's plenty more where that goes.
Do you think the smartest coyote
is smarter than the dumbest person?
Yeah.
Whoa.
That's deep.
Yeah.
I mean,
they live in places,
but I don't know if I could live there.
Wow.
So now what city has,
uh,
is there any city in the country that
actually has a legitimate problem with
coyotes?
Depends.
Have you talked to,
I mean,
La,
we definitely have our issues,
right?
I mean there's been bites.
There's been other situations been bitten.
Yeah.
Elysian park had some bites.
There's been bites down in Orange County.
It had some bites.
Are they biting homeless people?
Are they biting?
People would take naps.
What are the,
what do I do?
Um,
it's all over the board.
Usually it seems to be tied to people
been feeding it and so it's almost coming
up and biting like people on
the hands or people on the leg.
Um,
I don't think any of them know.
The ones I've heard had been like where
they're trying to take the person down
real type thing.
They've all been more like where
they're coming up and none of them,
none of them have.
Yes.
Do you heard about that woman
who was a folk singer in Canada?
They got killed a couple
of years back by coyotes.
Yeah.
I actually went up there a
couple of years after that.
They actually got a study going on,
coyotes up there.
They radio collared a bunch and I went
up there and helped him capture or the
first couple of animals to kind of see
what's going on and that's just a crazy
scenario up there.
It's way different than
what we see down here.
The coyotes first or
there eastern coyotes,
so they're a little bit bigger,
but they're also,
they,
they kind of,
there's very few food sources up there.
They're dealing with snowshoe hares,
which their cycles kind
of fluctuate up and down.
And so sometimes there can be tons of
food and other times there can be almost
none,
but they've learned that they can take
advantage of Moose during the winter and
they're actually killing
Moose in the snow.
What you'd think of this
little 40 pound animal,
take it on this huge moose,
but they're seeing it.
They do these snow surveys and they're
finding these dead moose that were very
clearly killed by coyotes.
Wow.
So a full grown Mousse.
Yeah.
That's insane.
A full grown moose is like
more than a thousand pounds.
Yeah.
I know.
It's,
it's amazing.
I mean,
obviously these moose in the winter,
the snow gets deep,
so there they're definitely,
they can get stuck in things and that
type of scenario would they know that it's
coyotes and killed them and not wolves.
There's no wolves there.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
So I had Russian nurses running
from me and just crazy stories.
Like why were they trying to do to you?
Uh,
well,
this Russian nurse was in an allergist
office and she was giving wrong doses to
the kids and stuff of shots.
So I had all my documentation,
like these yellow pads that goes,
there's um,
we can see,
right,
I'm 22 years old.
You can see right here.
Then she tries to grab it.
Now it's a tug of war across a desk.
And I dunno what the fuck is going on.
And um,
she takes off and runs
down a hallway and I'm 22.
I'm like,
well shit,
I fucking run down the hallway afterwards
and she goes into a patient room and
10,
she locks the door and then I get the
door open and just somebody to unlock it.
And she's in there and she's
talking to her husband on the phone.
She goes,
Andrew,
there is a man here who's telling me lies.
He telling me lie,
I didn't want to tell you,
Lisa,
I am pregnant and I'm going to lose
the baby because of these moms that I'm
going
totally holy
freaking out.
So I teach a bunch of Vietnamese people
had a shit and it was one day I got away
a call.
Yeah,
I got a call from this guy.
Well they were her mungs.
Okay.
You know what Hmong is like this.
If you saw a Grand Torino,
that movie with Clint Eastwood,
I think the H is silent.
H.
M o.
U.
N.
G.
And then there are people without a land.
Yeah.
And then they all came to San Jose,
California to work in assembly plants.
So they're in this cable assembly pant.
A plant called Cable Co.
That was a big client of ours.
And I got a call from,
it's really cool guys.
And he was chip,
chip bronc because Al
you got to get down here.
You're not going to fucking believe it.
And I got a situation and I go,
what is it?
And it goes better.
You see
I want to go to the bathroom.
Shit everywhere.
What?
Cause they had never been used to toilets.
So they were standing on the toilet seats.
I found out that's what was going on.
They all had fake names like a,
the name is [inaudible],
but you can call me Keith.
Hey Keith,
fluke league.
Can you come here for a second?
Can I start with the shit everywhere?
Like on the ground?
Yeah.
They were missing.
It's a toilet seat is not
to fucking hold you up.
So they're waddling up there and they
were standing on the standing on the
toilets.
They were just used to like
shitting and shitting in holes.
Oh my God.
If they're lucky,
you know,
in the woods or whatever.
He said,
Jesus Christ.
So you're lucky.
Not Lucky where they hold it forever.
So yeah,
it is backed up.
Comes a brick.
Yeah.
So,
um,
anyway,
I gathered everybody around.
I just appointed a bathroom
monitor and oh my God,
a bathroom monitors.
So I had one of the guys
who was a supervisor,
I had a clipboard.
I put a lock on the map
room door and then she,
you become this corporate fixer.
That's what I was doing.
Story that didn't,
that we engaged in.
That's famous.
That's not about this journey.
I'll give you an example.
The protocol.
Sound
parable question seems religious
doesn't really make much sense.
Do you know the story?
Sure.
But why don't you lay it out?
So there's a father,
he has two sons and oldest son,
the younger son,
and he says to them,
who wants to spend their inheritance?
The younger says me that
don't go and spend it,
and the youngest son takes all the dough
and he runs off and sniffs coke off
stripper's tits for a number of years
until he realizes this is getting pretty
boring and I'm in a lot of trouble.
He ends up feeding,
throwing food to pigs.
That's his job.
And he can't even eat the food
that he gives to the pigs.
At which point he says,
Dad,
will you take me back?
That then goes to,
they don't meet.
This somehow happens.
Not through telephones.
It just happens at which point that
goes to the fatty carbs has killed the
fatted calf.
Oldest sons hustled on that.
What's going on?
I've stayed with you since the beginning.
I've been loyal to you and I hear the
stories of my younger brother coming back
who's been sniffing coke off stripper's
tits for the last topic on those how
many years and you're prepared
to kill the fatted calf.
W what's the SP that I want another story.
He says,
you're right son.
Don't worry about that.
You take a little side step,
a little step to the side.
You'll always be with me.
You're a good boy.
At which point he goes out
to meet the protocol son,
the wasteful son.
The waste will some returns and he says
you will awesome that you're found.
That's the end of the story
is quite hard to make sense
of that in a literal sense.
You go all dance was a bit unfair.
Me,
you should have been kind to the oldest
son cause he never ran off and did
anything.
But the essence of the story
is that you are the father.
You are enough.
Your oldest son is your intellect.
He says,
Oh,
don't do this.
Don't do that.
He's trying to reconcile,
make sense of a prosaic
and material world.
The younger son being the
wild feral entity that he is.
What's going out in the to
find out what it's all about.
Yeah.
So when he's recklessness
and sense of adventure,
he finds that he can't escape himself.
So we has to return to himself and at
which point he has to accept who he is,
which point the intellect is left out.
The equation pretty much is the older
brother because he can't understand the
significance of the journey
of the wasteful brother.
Any end,
you have to leave yourself to
understand the value of yourself.
You have to lose stuff before you realize
that all the stuff that you're losing
is a femoral and transitory.
It's not yours.
You are enough.
You are always enough,
but you've got to somehow prostitute
yourself before you realize your own value
factors is the essence of all stories.